how much do you think obama charges i
would have guessed 250 to 350k that's my
guess for like a speaking engagement
but honestly it could be more it could
be like double that dude so i think it's
i heard rumors it's in like the one two
1.2 million range
and that makes way wow obama is not
gonna get out of bed for less than a
million
[Music]
all right what's going on i have been
bursting at the seams to tell you a
story
you sent me the teaser you go i got the
best story
i was like all right let's hear it
you're like on the podcast not here i
was like okay well give me like a clue
can't say anything on the podcast so i'm
here now two days of a tease later let's
hear it all right so
there was this guy who you had in the
podcast the comedian hassan what's his
last name minaj
minhash yeah
his is it with an h
yeah so
i was out to eat with my friend jason
jason janowitz from uh block works on
saturday night and we were sitting
outside in new york city just having
dinner and i see hassan walk by i forget
his last name but it was hassan and his
i was like ah [__] i can't remember his
last name so i don't want to scream out
his last name but you know i know it's a
sign by the way he wants he pronounces
it
but but let's keep going husson sorry
and i see him walk by
and uh i go oh jason there's uh that guy
that he was on our pod i wasn't there
but he was there
should i should i go say what's up to
him and jason was like yeah just go do
it it's like all right fine he's already
made it down the block but that's okay
i'm gonna run so i get up from dinner
and i kind of like chase him down i was
like oh man i'm gonna look like a weirdo
but whatever he'll know
and i go hey hey and like people like
look at it like cv like
they think something's up i'm like no
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna grab them
and i cross the street and i finally
grab my go hassan what's going on man
and he turns around i go what's up dude
uh sorry i didn't mean to bother you he
was with he was with his girlfriend or
someone a girl and i was like hey man uh
it's me sam parr i think we chatted once
or twice on twitter but you're close
with sean and you were on the podcast i
wasn't there but i just wanted to say
hey i love your work
and he goes uh what i go yeah i'm just
like you know i'm sam from my first
million and he goes uh dude i've never
been on a package before
and i was like what do you mean you were
just on it he goes who do you think i am
i go you're hassan the comedian the
comedian right he goes no that's not me
and then uh i was like
oh my god i am so embarrassed dude i am
i was like surely you get that a lot
right he goes yeah like sometimes but
like it sounds tall i'm short and i was
like well i it was for a podcast and i
only saw his like upper torso and like
why am i even explaining this like this
doesn't even make sense so i turn around
and i walk away and he and he goes hey
man um
and he and then he chases me down and he
goes what uh what podcast did you say i
was like
i told him originally mfm i go it's my
first million and he goes are you sam
parr i go yeah what's going on and he
goes check this out and he holds up his
phone and he had my first million up on
his spotify and he was like you know
previously listed again he totally knew
what was up and his girlfriend started
laughing and it went for being like the
most embarrassing thing i'd done all
year to it kind of worked out
after a while it was horrendous like i'm
getting chills just discussing
can't i was so embarrassed
i'm so thankful he didn't say like what
do you think all indian guys look alike
uh but
it was quite bad that's hilarious
he um so the whole time when you were
first talking to him he didn't like be
like oh by the way like he waited to
realize like this podcast he was
listening to that you were him
yeah he was like wait are you and then
he it was just like the whole
interaction was incredibly uncomfortable
yeah it was it was a very weird
interaction
but uh like it went from being like i
was i was like
like i made this face like i made it a
cringe face to him i'm like oh my god i
can't believe this is gonna go on the
internet like this is going to be known
as like this guy thinks we all look
alike and it it worked out okay
dude
i have like um
i don't have real nightmares like scary
stuff happening to me my nightmares are
situations like this like uh i'll have
like a nightmare where it's like i'm at
a dinner
and i'm just i'm like trying to like
butter up like this person i'm trying to
like you know be friends with this
person and talk to them and make jokes
with them and the whole time i'm calling
the guy ross and like at the end
somebody's like why are you calling him
broths his name's rick
and i'm like [__] i've been calling on
ross for one hour
or like
micro cringe moments or like when
someone nice uh or someone who you want
to impress like i remember i had this
guy uh i was trying to work at their
company and i was interviewing and he's
like what's going on
and you reply with good
it's the worst
you too
yes oh
right now you work here never mind
i'm sorry that i said that
it's one of those things uh all right
let me let me ask you a question actual
horrible crit can i tell you the actual
horrible this is not even funny
uh this is more like a confessional for
me you're like you know forgive me
father i have sin type of thing
i was at a holiday party once and
some some woman came up to to like our
table she like knew the person i was
talking to i didn't really know her but
i think i had met her once before it was
so vague in my head
and i was like oh like when's the little
one do or wins a little one coming and
she had just had the baby
and i was like oh my
and i'm i was a 24 year old dude and in
that moment i was like
like it took me a second to even
understand what i had done
and how bad it was and i was just
sitting there with a stupid look on my
face
and i didn't know what to say like too
much time past even like like two beats
had passed now i couldn't even apologize
she had tried to like move on to like
spare me the cringe
and i knew she's feeling bad and i'm
feeling
equally bad and i literally this is 10
years ago
and like i still feel it the same way i
did in that moment because i've never
recovered like it's been the same
feeling for 10 years straight yeah
that's embarrassing it makes me feel
horrible
yeah just don't say anything dude don't
talk to anyone that's like the only
motto is do a podcast with your friend
and speak to nobody else that's the only
way i uh
i mean that mistake you made like that's
i think that's a mistake that many
people make one time and one time only
then you just never asked about
pregnancy you just never the most
awkward thing is sometimes if they ask
you if you want to touch their belly i
don't ever do that
who asks you nobody asked that dude i
remember my belly well like you like
well like you know there's like kids
like when you're younger it's like hey
do you want to feel the baby kick when
you're like four i remember like someone
asked me that right when i cross that
threshold of what is like no i don't
want to touch a grown woman's stomach
and like i i distinctly remember that
around like 14 years old or 12 years old
i was like i think i'm i think i'm past
that point this week we went to the
point where like i don't want my parents
to see me naked anymore like whenever
that whenever that age is that
[Laughter]
you know what i mean when i was 15 and i
stopped showering with my dog
it's just like there's like a distinct
it's like it's hard to say what it is
but you know it's before and after
yeah life is actually like people said
what's the meaning of life in life the
meaning of life is to just avoid those
exact moments that we're talking about
that's really the only purpose of life
is to try to just avoid these
horrendous seconds that can that will
come up dude can we brag about being the
number one podcast and that be like a
thing
all right uh yeah so this weekend we
were number one in the business category
we were number one in entrepreneurship
we were number 40 i think in all of
america
uh what are we right now did it stay the
same
uh yeah i don't know i didn't check but
just that screenshot was incredible i
mean like you see tim ferriss's podcast
like dude i remember like i've been
listening to that i've been a fan of him
for a long time
and even though i know these charts are
they're not like that doesn't mean we're
bigger than their podcast it just means
like the velocity like the just that we
grew
fast and so it moved us up higher that
week or whatever
um there's some like secret formula
but even still that secret formula the
fact that whatever the secret formula is
if we can be in that conversation on any
secret formula that's kind of a
that's kind of a cool moment and uh
i don't know if it's because we had some
pretty dope episodes with darmesh and
then peter levels and maybe some of the
growth stuff that jonathan's doing i
don't know exactly what i think it's all
the above kind of amazing
i think it's all the above i know that
they're like spending money to grow and
they're doing some promotions i don't
exactly know what and then darmesh uh
was popular and whenever darmesh comes
on afterwards i always see him doing
stuff like emailing it out to his email
list and doing things like that so he's
always promoting it and then peter
promoted his episode a ton so i think
that's why it happened but yeah we were
like
you know we like we're beating like
legitimately famous people like uh
like if you scroll through the top 50
podcasts in america you're like oh that
person like if i saw them i'd ask for a
picture and we're like ahead of a lot of
these people
that's the type of person who i'd be
very embarrassed if i said good when
they asked what's up
my uh my favorite there's a tweet from
this guy bengali underscore 87.
this is the tweet he goes
best business slash entrepreneurship
podcast out there
big money that is no small boy stuff i'm
gonna sample that john vp
i was like dude if that's not the new
motto of the podcast no small boy stuff
big money big money stuff no big money
that is no small bus stop i had um it's
just incredible when i was walking
around new york this weekend i had a
couple people throughout the day come up
to me and say they're they're listeners
and a few of them said uh i'm your dog
you know because that guy uh we had an
episode where they got what would he
what did he say he's like hey i want to
work for you i'm going to be your dog
the dog
dylan i'm dylan the dog i'm you're not a
dog
[Laughter]
um all right let me ask you something
that's good [__]
yeah uh you get paid to speak sometimes
right
uh sometimes i say no most of the time
because yeah so most of the time but
i've done it a couple times it's kind of
crazy to
like it's kind of crazy when you say the
number you're like all right yeah okay
i'll come talk but it's going to be 10
grand and they're like okay great and
you're just like wow 10 grand just to
talk like you know so i think that's
unfortunate like you know i like
not that i would do this for free but it
just seems like something you shouldn't
have like
it seems like something that's so weird
to pay for and i know i get it i get the
logic it's like
you have an event you kind of need like
someone to give an appearance if that
person matters to your community that's
cool if you think they're going to add
some value
great
but it is just wild like isn't there a
part of you that just like still
remembers being like totally broke and
you're just like what the hell is
happening you could just i can do this
one zoom call for 12 grand that's insane
well i've never done a zoom call like
that but so hubspot they have their
conference coming are you gonna speak at
the conference we're supposed to speak
are you gonna fly out or no
tbd only if they pay me 50 grand
yeah you'll have to take that up with
them but
obama is gonna talk obama's talking and
then like a couple years ago they had
oprah oprah talking and i did some
research how much do you think if you're
obama and oprah i would put them in
similar categories maybe obama a little
bit above in terms of influence but not
like terribly above how much do you
think and i didn't ask them i just
researched it and i like try to find
contracts how much do you think obama
charges
i would guess something between
i would have guessed 250 to 350k that's
my guess for like a speaking engagement
but honestly it could be more it could
be like double that dude so i think it's
i heard rumors it's in like the one two
one point two million range
and that makes sense wow obama is not
gonna get out of bed for less than a
million and i hear oprah is around the 1
million no small boy stuff for obama too
no definitely not and so here's why so
i've heard like rumors and i talked to
people that have had them before and
that's kind of how it came with that
number but let me give you some insider
numbers so i only had one paid speaker
ever at hustlecon so at halsacon
collectively we probably had
200 or 300 speakers over a couple years
a handful of years
casey neistat was the only speaker that
we had who we paid and i was supposed to
you're not supposed to talk about how
much you pay him but like this was like
years ago so i can do it this was i
think at the height of his popularity
i only paid him 25 000
plus a private flight from la to san
francis san francisco for six thousand
dollars orders from san francisco to l.a
i forget but one way it was only six
grand plus twenty-five thousand dollars
that's nothing right
twenty-five percent of cheap compared to
what cause he was at the peak of his
powers at that time too right it's not
like yeah yeah for sure
not like some c-list you know person who
used to be famous it's like no guys he's
not that was a big deal then he's a big
deal now too so i tried to get gary
vaynerchuk to come speak at an event
once and he offered uh his asking price
was a hundred thousand dollars or i
think he said that you would have to buy
a hundred thousand dollars worth of
books and that somehow like pushes them
up the charts or
something like that and uh
so gary vaynerchuk was a hundred grand
um and i got speak i i spoke somewhat
recently and i asked i got paid 25 to 20
20 to 25 thousand dollars or maybe it
was 20 grand plus flights and then i
think that we had uh ashton kutcher
spoke at an event that i was at and the
uh
the organizers like kind of like implied
like they paid them around 150 grand
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better this has
always been the playbook like i met a
guy once who was writing a book and i
was like nice like you know what's your
goals for the book and like he was kind
of answering me but i got the sense like
i feel like you know you ever hear a
story and you're like i feel like you're
leaving out the one important detail
that makes all of this make sense
like you're not
saying the wrong thing but i feel like
you're just not saying whatever the
right thing is
and sure enough like 20 minutes and he's
like
yeah basically you write books so that
you can get paid speaking gigs like it
doesn't matter who reads your book or
how you just need to be a guy who writes
a book and then you like do a thing you
like pay a certain amount to get like up
in the chart so you could say new york
times best seller or like
you know amazon best seller
and
and then that just increases your paid
speaking rate
by like 15k
and then that's like you know how you
make your money back for this whole like
book process
and i was like oh okay that makes way
more sense like now i understand and i
was like so this paid speaking gig like
how does this work and he kind of broke
it down for me kind of step by step
and i remember being intrigued but also
you know the cost of like
you know basically like the idea of like
oh yeah what you do is you fly around
like you basically have to go you're
never home you're flying around all the
time so he was at that point trying to
figure out all right
the next step after this you know and i
sort of started thinking about okay what
is the move straight to the end version
of this
and i was like oh okay i think i know
what i would do it's like i would do a
this is how like i was thinking about
the podcast at this time like i was
thinking about creating one i was like i
think i would do a podcast that i could
just record right here whenever i want
maybe in batches
and as long as the conversation's fun i
don't think i would care about making
any money off that
and i feel like if i could do that i
could get like
you know what if like a million people
were fans of the podcast i feel like
that would just jump me where all these
guys are trying to go or they're like
ultimately i think what a lot of people
want is like
they
have a topic that they're really curious
about that they like to research they
like to do experiments in and they're
just trying to figure out a way to get
paid to be professionally curious about
that thing i think that's like the
generous version of like how to think
about this there's like the skeptical
version of which is just like oh dude
you're just like some motivational
speaker like sort of scammy guru guy who
wants to go around and blah blah blah
but i think the re the earnest people i
think they just want to be
professionally curious it's like how do
i get to spend 90 of my time just like
digging in on this topic i'm a nerd
about and then like somehow translate
the other 10 of my time into enough
money to fund me to do that in a in a
cool way um and so i think that that you
know that's how i think about this stuff
what i've been doing for speaking is i
actually haven't asked to be paid lately
but i do tell them i need two first
class flights
um and i want you to pay entirely for
the hotel for a week and i will only say
yes if it's so my wife and i basically
so we can go to
a cool place so i'll only say yes but
let me tell you something interesting so
robert de niro he uh so the wall street
journal did this thing where meech our
friend ramitz shared it so listen to
robert so here's what robert denial got
paid so he did a movie called savage
salvation in september 2020 he got paid
11 million dollars so he was going to be
there for eight days
he asked for a round-trip private air
transportation on a gulf stream five is
that or six i don't know how roman
numerals work but a gulf stream jet he
uh got to keep all of the costumes wigs
and prosthetics all the stuff that he
wore on this on the plane or all the
stuff he wore in the movie he got to
keep all of it he wanted an additional
fee for his uh
personal trainer he had to come and be
flown there and he had to be put up at
the ritz carlton
in addition to the the 10 days that he
had or the eight days he had to be there
for production he wanted a seven day va
all expenses paid vacation to the ritz
carlton
followed by a vacation in puerto rico
where you also had to pay for his jet
and i had to take his whole family uh to
and from uh and then finally he wanted
one round-trip jet fra
one round-trip private flight jet
between new york and ella day in la for
a five-day stay anytime within 12 months
those are all of his ass in his contract
for all for eight days of work that's
not bad
this is cool it's like a hostage
negotiation it's like i need a briefcase
with the cash and i need a
jet that's fueled with the engine on and
i'm gonna get on it dude check out this
website i just sent you wsb.com
so i had once heard that like um
you know like coach k who who's the co
the basketball coach at duke um
i remember back in the day he kind of
had like a salary of like uh i want to
call it like not back in the day but
like
he's the number one college basketball
coach most winningest coach of all time
whatever you're curious how much does he
make
shishevsky is his last name it's like
spelled with a k and then a bunch of
yeah yeah yeah okay so um
so he's now like 75. he's like at the
top of his game he just retired so he
was making 12 and a half million a year
to coach college basketball at the time
um and i think that like
but i remember when i was in school
because i went to duke i remember
reading at that time his salary was like
maybe half that it was closer to like
four or five million
and he had gotten offered a contract
with the lakers that was going to pay
him over 10 million and he turned it
down
and i remember just thinking wow this
guy like 10 million a year i was like
the guy turned down like basically an
extra 50 million dollars to go do this
deal like that's pretty impressive like
why um you know why did he do that
and
i started looking into like how he makes
his money and basically he makes more
money i believe
uh or at the time he was making more
money through his endorsements speaking
fees books tours things like that than
he was his like actual day job and so if
you go to the site wsb.com he's listed
on there and it says
you can see a bunch of speakers and you
can see how much they charge so bob iger
the chairman to disney it's like says
like you know you got a contact for fees
for coach k his says like 70 000 plus is
his speaking fee
and so you want to go get this guy it's
70 000 plus and so there's these
businesses that are basically these
booking agencies
for well-known speakers and i feel like
this is like a really interesting little
niche business to be these like
middleman agencies that just aggregate
demand for
this like you know roster of speakers
that they can book out so you know how
basically like maybe eight years ago we
kind of laughed at youtubers and it's
like there's they're not real
celebrities they're just internet
celebrities or they're not they can't
they're not gonna be real business
people but now you know like there's a
world where some of them are going to be
billionaires
and uh then yeah it had a vibe that was
like
oh you make videos that's cute yeah it
says yes like a a condescending type of
vibe and now that there's uh we had the
guy i forget his name but he was on the
pod and he uh he's the uh founder of the
management company that manages mr beast
what was his name
you know i'm talking about read
read yes read and night media
and like there it's like this is like
potentially gonna be a pretty large
business
do you think that these type of speaker
bureaus and these some of these agencies
what are the twitter boys gonna get them
love huh you think like
is like uh is there gonna be like a like
you know we didn't boys is there going
to be a is there going to be a twitter
agency for sahil bloom and and sean
perry anytime soon
well there should be right you said
you're getting paid to speak silent gets
paid to speak i get paid to speak
so obviously there is demand we already
are doing the behavior we just haven't
gotten rolled up like
these guys you know we're we don't have
enough you know sort of gray hair on our
chest to go get on to one of these like
rolodexes of like you know whatever
washington speaker bureau
um but why not right like i i do think
so and i think cameo kind of
shows the demand for this sort of thing
because people are willing to pay
you know 100 bucks a pop for these like
15 to 30 second videos from like uh
you know tier two two or three two or
four celebrity uh you know just saying
happy birthday or whatever
uh and i think cami was trying to go
upstream where they're like yeah you
could do meet and greets you could do
corporate appearances you're trying i
think cameos trying to move into that
space but yeah i think definitely
somebody could create a little bit of a
um
you know one of these like speaker
speaker businesses that like basically
books out
podcasters
youtubers twitter boys like you know
tick-tock stars to go and talk at you
know corporate events and and marketing
events stuff like that
guess how much revenue this company
washington speaker bureaus does
oh god
okay my guess 30 million a year
so
they were acquired in the year 2000. the
year they required they're doing 15
million they're bought by uh
this company that i forget it's one of
the ad agencies that sounds like the
covid name is it omnicrom i forget what
it was like one of the like there's one
there's like there's basically like five
ad agencies that owns like everything i
forget which one it is
and uh when they require they are doing
15 million but that was in 1999 in 2000
and seventeen they did 150 million
in revenue
[__] crazy right yes
by the way wild right you want to know a
homie move homie move whenever somebody
asks you to guess something always guess
low
no bigger [__] on you feeling than you
guess they're trying to impress you with
some fun fact about how cool this thing
is and you guessed too high and they're
like well no i mean it's not it's not
that good
and then it sort of just takes all the
wind out of it so the
the homie move is always whatever you
think it is cut it in half so that they
can have the win of being like no
it's even more you're like what that's
crazy right like that's how you do it
that's good what do you want to do now
oh there are more i'm just scrolling
this thing dude
terry bradshaw 40k we can go get terry
bradshaw this guy's got four super bowl
rings
good old terry you can get him for 40k
too i don't care about him that much but
uh i i yeah we should get some more
people i heard a rumor another rumor
that we could have gotten arnold
schwarzenegger on our podcast for 100k
um i don't know if that was like a
one-off thing but there was like some
consideration i'd heard about it and i
i i mean
arnold's pretty cool i don't think i
would spend a hundred thousand i don't
think he could give us a hund i don't
think he would give the podcast a
hundred a hundred thousand dollars worth
of promotion
right people have asked me this before
what do you think is the what would be
your dream guest if we just had one
if there's just a hundred thousand
dollar budget that was gonna go to
somebody guarantee that they come on the
pod who would be your your person that
you would put on there
i mean it's got to be like someone
really famous so definitely like an elon
or
uh like an obama or a trump like a
president
uh like who would be the most famous
person that you could ask them questions
is that because you're thinking what
drives the most like clicks or is it
more like that's the person i would want
to have a pot yeah no i don't think i
don't know if i would enjoy a
conversation with elon like i think that
would be an uncomfortable situation i
think i don't think that would be
particularly enjoyable do you
i i 100 agree with you i think it would
be honestly sort of uncomfortable in a
giant like
it's almost an automatic letdown it's
like you're going to have such high
hopes and expectations i want it to go
so well it's gonna be kind of a
difficult conversation it's gonna like
fly by really quickly
there's gonna be 15 minutes we're like
[__] we've been talking about this for
15 minutes like oh no i need to like
switch course here
um he's not gonna know the vibe he's not
gonna like he's not gonna come like
ready to do what we do well which is
like you know shoot the [__] and kind of
brainstorm and tell stories
so i'm not sure that that would be
i would i would go for somebody if i was
gonna pull one one like that i would
just be like who is the best person that
would actually love the type of
conversation that we have and be great
at it i think that's a little bit hard i
think that
you know
i think you'd have to take this
archetype of like who is the kind of
like an idea machine
but also
has like name and reputation has done
stuff
and um
i think peter
should even give a [__] i think peter
thiel might be interesting but he's not
that famous so i don't know how much
traffic he would drive
oh i think he i think he drives a good
amount especially like in our niche i
think i think people because he doesn't
do a lot of content right like you can
go get like on the site you can go get
damon john from shark tank and it's like
but for 40k but he's everywhere dude
like first of all
come on i mean fubu was cool but like
yeah i mean it's what we want
and secondly like you know um i i don't
think he and he does appearances
everywhere so you need somebody who
people are sort of starved for content
from maybe it's like a naval or peter
thiel somebody somebody who
intentionally limits their number of
experiences so that
you know you're high search demand and
not a lot of like hits coming up yeah i
don't know i i wouldn't want it to be
him i would want i don't i don't care
about that guy i can't think of any
other examples though uh
i don't [__] know i would be
uncomfortable with anyone anyone who's
like intimidatingly good i'd be
uncomfortable being around like if i
made a joke to elon he wouldn't laugh i
don't think he would laugh i think obama
would definitely laugh at everything
even if he would it's one of those type
of guys where you would say something
and he would giggle and it's like wait
what did i say he's like i don't know i
just i the the
tone of your voice i thought i was
supposed to laugh so i did
um right
i'm so trained on socializing that i
don't actually need to be here for this
i could just autopilot mimic all of the
things i need to do socially for this to
be a positive experience for you
right uh i don't know who i'd want for a
hundred grand okay all right so we have
someone here but before we get to that
person tell me uh
about sarah moore
can i do this yeah can i do the ceremony
update okay this is kind of incredible
in fact this should probably move to the
beginning of the episode it's probably
the most interesting bit
so a while back maybe a month ago
i came on here and i was like um
dude there's this business have you
heard of this business called
eggcartons.com
and you're like no what is that well
that's exactly what it sounds like you
go to eggcartons.com and it's a place
where you can buy the packaging the
carton for eggs um and like but also
packaging for a bunch of different
varieties of eggs like huge shipments
small ones eco-friendly not eco-friendly
but also just like in general like other
packaging materials as well
so i was like yeah fascinating business
right like you go there it's an old
school looking website you know it's
like dial 1 800 eggs dot com whatever
like to call us to place an order and i
was like this is fascinating so i dug in
i was like who's behind this and i
basically found that it used to be owned
by this guy he ran it for 24 years i was
like okay this sounds about right you
know his linkedin picture was him like
with a you know like a phone with a cord
in it and he's like got it up to his
neck and he's like sitting at a messy
desk and i was like ah this looks like
the guy who started edcard.com 25 years
ago
but now as i noticed oh it says like he
ended his ownership one year ago so who
who's behind this and i saw that there
was this woman named sarah moore who was
like not what you would expect to be
like it's like oh this person should be
like the ceo of lululemon or something
like that why is she getting into egg
cartons of alcohol
beautiful harvard graduate
yeah like you're he looks like a
celebrity a little bit um
and so i tried to reach out to her i
couldn't get a hold of her and but i
couldn't resist so i came on the pod and
i told the story it's like yeah so
basically it looks like she purchased
this business uh she did like one tiny
interview about it and
but i had done one thing that i didn't
tell you about i don't think that day
which is
i've been experimenting with a format
that i wish people use more on me like
when people reach out to me they're like
oh i'd love to talk to you sometime like
if you have a question just send me the
question in fact if you have a bunch of
questions like just send me a google doc
i'm going to look at it and if i want to
answer i'll answer if i don't i don't
and so that's what i did to her i go
i sent her an email i said egg cartons
like with five exclamation points i go
that's hilarious like what a hilarious
niche okay we got this podcast i'd love
to feature you on it um i have five
questions for you on this google doc if
you answer them with bullet points i'll
tell your story on the podcast we get 20
million dollars a year it'll be great
for your business i go this is me on
twitter by the way whatever i sent it
no reply for
20 days
um
then she go she emails me out of the
blue she goes i couldn't have paid
someone to make me sound as cool as you
and sam did on the podcast last week
thank you so much i filled out your
google doc i think they'll answer your
questions i would have responded earlier
if i didn't think this was spam um blah
blah send me send me your address i'll
send you some world-class egg cards
right so i want to read you what she
what what what
what she replied but did you want any
are you gonna are you gonna accept those
cartons
very nice really very nice
very nice of you sarah but thank you but
no thank you thank you
no dude everything in the house could
turn into like a toy storage container
i have toys forever all shapes and sizes
all right so all right what did you say
so i basically said here's my question i
go you go you bought eggcards.com did
you buy it alone as part of a pe firm
she goes alone-ish i started a pe firm
alone to buy a business but it wasn't
your typical pe firm my office my
quote-unquote office was just a library
at school there was no fund
like no money i had a lot of help i had
over 50 unpaid interns come from
craigslist and i had them sift through
over 400 000 private companies for a
year and a half before i found
eggcartons.com
what
yeah i know then i go
i so that was my first question the
second question i go how the heck did
you buy it uh oh no why the heck did you
buy it what about the business made you
want to buy it was it the name the
customer retention what drove you to it
she goes my goal was to buy a business
with all debt so i could have 100
ownership i had no collateral though
except for my 2012 rav4
so
i was trying to find something that was
already stable enough that i could pitch
a bank that the business itself was the
collateral instead of my rav4
um that so i needed historical cash
flows this business fit because it had
been profitable since it started in 2001
had a high barrier to entry given the
domain name and 100 plus other similar
domain names that they own like egg
cartons like misspelled eggcarton.com
then she says the founder has usually
purchased all these domains over the
years to protect their like their demote
it was simple enough it was also a
simple enough business that somebody
with zero operational experience me
and average intelligence me could
operate if they tried hard enough
i was like wow this is incredible
then
i said i said i live in silicon valley
people here are obsessed with crypto ai
blah blah blah they would underestimate
edcards.com can you give us a sense of
the scale of the business that's a
really good way to frame that
that's a that's a beautiful way to frame
that question
because you nagged her a little bit like
you said something a little rude you're
like yeah you know it's probably not
that big but maybe it is you know like
impress me right i would think this is
small
but you know
i'd love to be surprised would you say
that this is more than this and less
than this and so she anyway she came
back with
i'm in the middle of something that
prevents me from sharing the numbers
publicly uh all i can say is that our
revenue is less than 50 million
and i was like oh okay okay but that you
not less than 20 if it was less than 20
i feel like you would have said less
than 20. i feel like that that would be
the case
um i said how did you negotiate the deal
she's like ah there's a bunch of
contacts here she goes in summary i
harassed the owner until he replied then
we hit it off we came up with the
valuation together then i contacted over
100 banks most of which told me to f off
one of them threw me a bone and agreed
to an under uncollateralized loan the
final deal was 75 bank debt and 25 the
seller's note so she bought this with no
money down
like the bank financing and the seller
financed it
she said before buying the business i
had i i overpaid an accountant to check
my work and do an audit of the business
because frankly i had no idea what i was
doing his fees got rolled into the deal
itself so uh she used an accountant to
cover her ass but also paid him out of
the deal itself
this is amazing any other fun tidbits or
anecdotes i i could share she here's
what she says this is where it gets
great she goes
while searching for the business i
participated in several research studies
just to make money uh like to while i
was doing my search i went from i went
legally blind from a deodorant study for
a bit so i had to take a break from
working from work until i could read
again
she goes my response rate was awful i
started doing borderline insane things
to get a reply at one point i took a
photo of myself wearing a sweatshirt
that said i want to buy your business
with a massive grin and i faxed it out
to thousands of businesses a day
to this day i run into owners who
recognize me from those faxes one of
those owners is actually my neighbor
then she says the library we worked out
of required a school id to enter most of
my interns didn't go to the school so we
had to get fake ids for all the interns
to get into the library every time we
hired someone there was a lag because we
would need to get more ids
during co before covert i used to fly to
china i needed to examine the egg
cartons on my first trip to india i got
held by indian customs and interrogation
for hours because they didn't believe
that i was coming to india alone they
did not believe that i was coming to
investigate egg cartons
uh related to india i almost got killed
there i rejected a shipment from an
indian vendor the his whole family lived
there he was furious started chasing
after me the hotel put me into
incredible mode for my safety my driver
luckily was at the door that i ran out
of otherwise i'd probably still be there
buried underground
um she goes when i bought the business i
considered it an egg company but now i
think of it as specialty packaging 40 of
our business comes from things
entirely unrelated to eggs you'd be very
surprised by our customer base you know
think big brands like boeing spacex
disney madison square garden crayola et
cetera anything that requires protection
and separation is fair game
um anyways there's one one more i should
say but dude what's the other one
is sarah moore not my hero is she my
hero is she not my hero this woman's
wonderful why is she why didn't she talk
about this publicly more often this is
like it i feel like there was tons and
tons of stories there
dude you know
people who there's some people who are
so in the game
that they're like
they're like oh yeah what am i going to
stop and chat about the game like i'm in
the [__] game right like that's the
feeling i get from her i've met some
people that i like this that they sort
of like it's a combination of
they kind of don't realize how
story-worthy their story is until like
quite a bit later and the second thing
they're sort of like you know either
they just prefer privacy or they're like
yeah i don't really know why i need to
do that so why would i do that it's
going to be kind of braggy and kind of
weird and what's the benefit and maybe
i'd just rather be personal
so i think that like i know a handful of
people that i'm like dude i wish i could
tell their story on the podcast because
they're epic but they just don't see
value in this and they're also not
consumers of it that's the other thing
i've noticed most of those people don't
listen to a bunch of podcasts or take
inspiration from it so it's kind of a
foreign idea to them they're like
they're like people will care it's like
yeah of course people will care about
this this is awesome um so anyways i was
totally inspired by this story and she
is uh kind of amazing she is one of us
she no small boy stuff for sarah moore
so i think she's only when you if you
google her you basically can't find
anything i mean there's next to nothing
on her there's like one or two pictures
there's very little i found one article
where it says that she's 28 and she uh
it says she answered a question what
inspired you to start buying companies
she says freedom what is your mantra
don't take counsel from your fears like
that's pretty much all she and like she
answered nothing this woman's amazing
why can't we find anything about her
there's a lot there's a lot going on
with her we need to uh we convince her
to come on
there's a 30 chance she's a fat guy
named craig so like you know we could be
getting catfished here i wouldn't put it
past her uh but
i'm gonna go with the with what i see i
think i think she's amazing
[Music]
you